petite promenade boulevard saint-laurent
pour illies adaf tahri regard un peu
nostalgique vers son lieu de travail et
n'a pas mis les pieds à l' agence de
publicité touché depuis la mi mars
il est en télétravail ça se passe bien
mais il commence à s'ennuyer
c'est le contact humain qui marque
beaucoup dans notre métier c'est très
créatif c'est beaucoup de réflexion
beaucoup de travail d'équipé pour nous
rencontrer
c'est la première fois en trois mois que
sa patronne karine courtemanche entrait
dans les bureaux de lagence la vie ici
s'est arrêtée subitement le 13 mars
depuis les 215 employés travaillent tous
deux la maison c'est un peu triste parce
que ce qui fait qu'on aime l'espace de
travail c'est beaucoup plus que le
mobilier
ce sont les jalons et demi elle admet
que le télétravail a fait ses preuves
plus encore qu'elle ne l'aurait cru mais
a quand même bien hâte de revoir son
monde
elle vise le 1er septembre je pense que
c'est une notion de productivité je
pense est une notion de bonheur au
bureau et est d'être capable de sentir
accomplis dans la fenêtre quelques
post-it ci et là démontre que la
planification du retour des employés a
commencé seulement 25 % d'entre eux
pourraient devoir être présents en même
temps dans la première phase nos
sondages du conte à environ 35% nous en
pays qui serait prête à rentrer demain
matin si si on était dans une situation
sécuritaire pour le faire
à voir à quel point les rues du
centre-ville sont tranquilles cet été
facile de deviner que tous les gros
employeurs de montréal se sont mis au
télétravail au complexe desjardins par
exemple 150 employés seulement sont
présents aujourd'hui sur les 6800
habituel à la sun life
ils sont à peine une quarantaine dans
les bureaux sur plus de 2000 les 1900
employés de lloyd sont tous en
télétravail leurs locaux sont encore
fermés l'édifice d'hydro-québec est
quasi désert lui aussi au cours de
l'automne le retour complet au travail
sera impossible
on les a déjà cette information parce
que la situation sociale on s'attend à
ce qu'elle demeure à quel point ce sera
à voir
même son cloche à la banque nationale
prudente quant au retour de ses employés
au siège social seulement un sur dix est
présent comme tu peux voir si
aujourd'hui la ja personnes généralement
six habitées par les gens du marketing
et des affaires publiques
dany déry fait partie du comité de
gestion de crise mis sur pied par la
banque
il nous montre les pastilles au sol
placé en vue du retour des employés
bureau et classeurs ont aussi été
identifiés pour eux les personnes
peuvent revenir on peut re présentement
en petits groupes avec toutes les
mesures pour venir travailler en équipe
il y avait un besoin de permettre aux
gens de pouvoir revenir c'est un petit
20 pilotes je sais sur une et agissent
inhalent building et sausset c'est très
concluant les obstacles imposés par la
santé publique sont nombreux exemple
avec les ascenseurs
seulement deux personnes maximum peuvent
s'y retrouver en même temps le retour
des travailleurs ici aussi sera donc
très progressif au grand dam des petits
commerçants autour depuis quatre mois le
montréal souterrain est presque désert
est très difficile aujourd'hui c'est
venu mais s'il n'y a personne j'attends
les mondes qui retournent au travail
on dirait qu'on ait oublié là il n'y a
pas de monde ici tout le monde était de
travail mais nous on a le loyer à payer
on a toutes les dépenses et il n'y a
personne qui nous les milieux d'affaires
sont inquiets ils réclament des balises
un protocole clair pour ramener des
employés au centre ville
ils veulent aussi plus dead on attend
toujours les budgets je suis estomaqué
par la lenteur lancement et deuxièmement
je suis fier parce qu'effectivement les
entreprises m'avait dit un mot michel on
s'attache il y avait pourtant nos
employés kerviel si l'auteur or on est
loin de ça je suis persuadé que c'est
facile c'est faisable de mettre en place
la distanciation deux mètres de diminuer
le nombre de chats raison des salles de
conférences de donner la possibilité aux
travailleurs de réserver une place en
bureau de porter son mas québec juge
qu'il est encore trop tôt pour le faire
le centre ville de montréal risquent de
rester calme encore un certain temps ici
jean-sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal
[Musique]